so the following discussion is one I had
with the author Nicholas Kotar who
writes epic fantasy fiction based on
Russian fairy tales and it was a really
interesting reason to discuss token and
fairy tales in general traditional
storytelling and how it compares to
history and so we go into all of that
it's it's pretty interesting there's up
there's a two-minute little part of the
interview where the file gets a bit
choppy you can still follow the
discussion but it gets a little bit
difficult so don't worry just last two
minutes and then after that everything
returns to normal and it's fine and so
so stay tuned at the end of the the
video I've had a few more things to say
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Applause]
though hello everybody I am here with
Nicolas Qatar I hope I'm saying that
right Nicolas is an author he's a deacon
in the Orthodox Church but he's also an
author of fantasy fiction
he's written articles for the Orthodox
art journal and I'm sure he's also a
translator and it's he's a he's a smart
guy
and I met him as he wrote an article for
the Orthodox Arsenal about the lives of
the Saints and the way that he
approached the lives of the Saints
through a different vision really
excited me because it connected with the
way I see storytelling as let's say as a
structure around which reality kind of
manifests itself and he's also written
some articles connecting the lives of
the Saints to to otoki ins work and so a
lot of interesting things to talk about
and so maybe Nicolas you can introduce
yourself a little bit and maybe talk
just briefly about the work that you're
doing and the novel that you're writing
and then we'll go on with the interview
okay well the novel's I'm writing
come out of a very long period of
thinking about the need for storytelling
in the modern world and what that
storytelling should look like and it
also comes from my own deep desire to
tell the kinds of stories that Tolkien
told and because they've resonated with
me and with so many people throughout
these these Dead's decades on a very
very profound level when I went to
seminary I had to start to reassess a
lot of my worldview as odd as that might
sound in seminary usually you'd think
you'd come in you already have a
worldview formed but that's not the case
you have to come up against a lot of
misconceptions that you might have
against against a lot of difficult
realities that the church manifests
within the world because it's a it's not
a purely divine institution that exists
out there somewhere but it's you know
it's in meshed together with humanity
with all those all those problems and
one thing that I came up against came up
against again and again was the reality
of the church's way of storytelling and
how it didn't mesh very well with
with the way the history is told
nowadays and it fascinated me and I
remembered my first encounter with this
with the sort of this sort of disconnect
between modern historiography and a
geography I was still in college at that
point in University of California
Berkeley this was at a class of Russian
Eastern European and Eurasian studies it
was a kind of a survey course for
undergraduates and my professor was
talking about the life of st. st.
Vladimir the Baptizer of ruse and he
kind of laughed very kind of
provocatively at the idea that that he
could that he could be a monogamist
after after his conversion to
Christianity because for those who don't
know Vladimir was a famous womanizer I
mean he was and if any of you have had
the pleasure of seeing the new Russian
movie about his early life called Viking
highly recommended by the way it shows
that aspect of his personality very well
it was kind of a more Viking than than
Roose a kind of a wild man loved his
women but something happened after he he
converted and and at least this is the
way the hagiography tells it and I was
really shocked that that everybody
seemed to laugh together with the
professor and not accepting the
possibility of this sea change yeah in
in st. Vladimir and it made me think and
maybe it made me realize that basically
and I learned later on in more
systematic fashion that modern
historians consider mostly geography to
be nothing more than legends you'll see
the icon of st.
Eustace over there I don't know if you
can see it in detail but he's he's very
symbolic for me because his story of
hunting the deer and finding the deer in
the wood and catching it and then seeing
the cross and the antlers and the Christ
from the cross begins to speak to me
convert of appears is actually several
different lives of saints and because of
that st. Christopher's sorry st. Eustace
as a life is considered to be legendary
by the Catholic Church so he he's he's
considered to not have existed and that
doesn't sit well with me because well
because that would mean you have to
throw out more than one baby with the
bathwater so when I was in seminary I
started to study this more
systematically and I came across this
this
in the modern mindset and a kind of
inability to accept the reality of
storytelling as it was always told
throughout history and replacing it with
the sort of positive positivistic
scientific method way of thinking about
history where the only thing you can
believe in are things that you can see
in the primary sources or or in the
secondary sources and things that can be
positively identified as having existed
and I had a problem with it because if
as a student of history I know that you
can't look at a document as a as a datum
in a scientific sense because it was
written by a human being with his own
preconceptions in a certain time period
which we don't understand very well and
if we don't try to encounter the point
of view of the person writing those
primary sources without stamping onto
that person the preconceptions of the
21st century then we're missing
everything that that primary source
might have to tell us
so actually um these these lies of the
saints even though they are
anachronistic very often in the modern
historiography sense they are actually
telling us something very profound it's
something very deep and they are telling
something that something to us that is
very true and for that reason the
Orthodox Church at least has never shied
away from his a geographical tradition
and and continues to have you know the
lives of the saints as part even of
liturgy so that's that's why where I
started to approach this question and
that's where I actually don't remember
who approached me to write the essay
whether I approached you or what but
anyway that's how that's how it started
right no III think that I totally agree
with you I think that's um that's a
place where we really connect in terms
of the way we see the world you know
when we when we look at any ancient
story you know people will read we'll
try to let's say they'll read The Iliad
and then they'll try to parse out of the
Iliad little bits that maybe they could
use and then retell a historical version
of what might have happened at Troy you
figure you have
why are you doing that why what is it
helping you with and in the process
missing the point of the Iliad
completely right it's nothing later
anymore but also missing missing the the
truth of the of the Iliad or the truth
of the Trojan War in the sense that the
way that the Greeks told the story of
the Trojan War encompasses what that
event was in their lives and in their
society what impact that event had in
their society so if you go back and now
you try to mince it up and kind of pull
out some some little bit of a historical
fact and you say well yes we're so happy
we found in the historical nugget and
you show it to the world
but now you don't understand why that
story is the basis of a large part of
Western civilization yeah you know
generated it Rover have any of any
importance and you can't understand the
story on its own terms and you can't
understand how how it can inform your
way of thinking or your way of dealing
with the outside world which is the
point of literature on some level as
well
so yeah and this sort of there's there's
an interesting philosopher whom I
haven't read too much but just to just a
little bit hans-georg gadamer I was mid
20th century philosopher he talks about
this approach towards history and he
says that it's like having a
conversation with someone where you're
staring at that person and you're not
talking to him you're just letting them
talk with a little notebook and you're
writing down everything that they say
and staring at the way that their
eyebrows move up and and you know the
open is hand moved that way let me write
that down that's important and you're
not talking that and so history is
you're examining history as though it's
some sort of a specimen while he says
that a much more holistic a much more
intelligent and much more productive way
of viewing history is to actually have a
conversation but which means actually
listening to it and then providing your
input in middle you know this sort of
image of a conversation between two
people meaning you come with your
preconceived notions but then you also
listen to the to the preconceptions of
of the people in that distant time
period and kind of transcending time in
that in that conversation and that's
really what what history should be you
should be encountering people from a
very distant time period in a way that
that makes them very real to and in a
way that can inform your own perspective
and you know and your own experience of
the world around you and it's it's
way to to make the world around you more
a more vivid in a more living place
which is a problem nowadays I think
because we do notice that people are
retreating from from the natural world
they're not seeing the world around them
in very clear in very beautiful colors
they're retreating to the comfort of
their computers and to the comfort of
the virtual realities and all in the
augmented realities I mean I don't know
if you read this from that but there was
this essay about underestimate under
estimating America's collapse that came
out a few days ago I forgot who wrote it
but you know it's what another one of
these doom and gloom things but what was
interesting is it was picked up by the
American Conservative and I think it was
Rod Dreher that added a little bit of
his own
context to it and he said he noted this
I'm sorry I mention this this is really
bringing the conversation a little bit
down from the heights of history but he
showed he showed a a tracker of the
number of views on on pornhub during the
missile disaster in Hawaii and right
before it happened it was at some like
extremely low point nobody was doing
anything because that was when you know
the warning was going on everybody's
freaking out nobody was on pornhub and
as soon as the the the warning was
revealed to be fake it the number of
users of pornhub shot up an incredible
percent like compared to the user data
for the last week before and last week
after it was it was completely a exactly
yeah and and this is I put to you that
this is a direct result of looking at
history and looking at the world in this
sort of incorrect hans-georg gadamer way
of looking at it trying to examine it
and seeing what you can what you need to
get out of it and using it for your own
advantage rather than having a
conversation with with history with
literature in a way that you can learn
that the perspective of people from a
different time period and help that
inform the way you live yeah and I think
that the way you live is really the
right way to see it that is the purpose
of studying these stories the purpose of
telling these stories isn't just to
gather all these all this data and facts
who knows exactly why you're doing it
the purpose is to find ways to live find
warnings about how not to live
and also to let's say create kind of
glue which hold your world together you
know I always talk about the patterns
that inform a world and when you read
fairy tales when you read old stories
when you read the Bible especially and
you encounter and you encounter that in
liturgy in liturgy because you live it
you know you're you're physically
engaged with it it's almost like you're
fine-tuning your perceptions and your
fine-tuning your soul to be living in a
you know in a in a proper or let's say
at least a colorful and alive in a live
manner instead of well it's dreary yeah
this dreary it didn't use it didn't used
to be a problem right I mean this is
something that people did naturally
before it it seems to be an issue with
with the modern postmodern whatever
human being but it used to be natural
because people who are raised with these
stories and these stories have been
retold in basically the same format
since this well since since we have
written records right before they've
written a lot of these to come from from
oral tradition and it's interesting I've
thought about this a lot and it seems to
me that that part of part of the reason
that the West has lost this connection
with the stories is of course be it's
it's it's lost its connection with with
its Christianity and in the reality of
of the world today is that and part of
the part of the disconnect between
people who consider themselves churchy
so to speak and people who are spiritual
but not religious maybe is that they
they're the worldviews are so are so
markedly different than that you could
be having a conversation and I'm not
talking about having conversation with
somebody in the past I'm talking about
having a normal conversation with
somebody across the table you could be
using the same word the same language
and the person across from the table
doesn't understand you at all where they
think they do but they don't and you
have basically people talking across
from each other you see this in the
ideological warfare that we see or in
that famous Kathy Newman Jordan Peterson
interview which which was you know
tremendous but but you know and and I'm
interested in transcending that that gap
you know personally that's why I write
the stories that I do to bring it back
full circle to what we're talking about
originally and I find that the medium of
fairy tales in particular and it's not
me that thinks this but I find them to
be particularly effective for people now
because they because people are no
longer interested or moved by the
traditional religious narrative whether
it's Christian whether it's whatever it
doesn't matter but people still respond
that have on a very intrinsic level to
the questions posed by fairytales and
this is something that for example
there's a Russian philosopher by the
name of Ivana Guillen who lived in the
late 19th early 20th century who writes
a lot about Russian fairy tales and he
has an article on the spiritual meaning
of fairy tales that I've translated
that's on my website and he basically
says if I can quote him a little bit he
says that the fairy tale he's talking
specific about the Russian fairy tale
but it's true of any fairy tale he says
that it asked questions like this sorry
oh yes questions like this what is
happiness is it enriches or not is it is
it in love or is it in freedom is it
perhaps in goodness and righteousness
what is self sacrificing 11 why why is
it important what is fate what does it
mean that smart people often get the
wrong end of the stick and idiots get
happiness I mean these are these are
very very profound questions that we
symptoms don't even think about on a
rational level but that worry us on a
very very deep and intrinsic level and
to tell to write novels from the
perspective of these stories is to talk
about those same questions that the
Stef's key was talking about in 19th
century or or any of the great realistic
novelists of the of the 18th 19th and
early 20th centuries but in a way that I
think now accesses people's experiences
in a more direct way because I don't
think that realistic fiction has the
same power to move people as it did in
19th century from whatever reason maybe
it's because we've gotten to a point
where where style Trump's substance I
mean some of some of the some of the
Pulitzer Prize winners of the last few
years in particular I'm thinking if the
Goldfinch I don't know if you've ever
read it by Donna Tartt
it's you know it won in 2007 I think
I remember correctly but I mean I
couldn't get through a hundred pages of
it it was like it was it was a long
exercise in writing pretty sentences
that while the characters were doing
extremely stupid juvenile things to each
other and and just had people just like
like the Russians say like a hamster in
a wheel just making the same mistakes
over and over and over and over again
not learning from them and just being
extremely unpleasant throughout the
whole process but it's described and
incredibly beautiful language so you're
supposed to be moved by it and I just
felt like throwing it against the wall
so maybe you can tell us a little about
because I've been my solution let's say
to the problem that we're told you know
now has been visual art you know going
back to traditional iconography to
medieval image Bob in the West and an
Orthodox icon in general and trying to a
lot of the traditional languages into
let's say a coherent visual language for
today I mean these videos trying to get
people to wake up to this so I'd like to
maybe you could a bit of how because
you're writing these novels so maybe you
can tell us a little about your process
and especially about how you you're
trying to bridge this gap with your with
your whole that you're working on well
for me it's it's all it goes because my
first experience with the fantasy genre
was what was but mostly Tolkien because
he he told the kind of story that seemed
to suggest a lot more than was written
on the page and it initially drove me
kind of crazy because I'm reading this
and I feel I'm feeling the level of I'm
not quite Scripture but certainly great
literature because there's an it's
talking about such such profound truths
and didn't me how he did it so I started
to study him a lot just in my own being
his critical literature and his essay on
fairy stories right which I used in my
in my third article for for the lives of
saints series he has a very interesting
and I'm not sure how a folklorist
consider him in terms of in terms of his
method very fairy tales but I don't care
because the way the way he's the
function of fairy tale makes so much
intrinsically and it really spoke to me
as a writer so I thought I would somehow
repeat his process and basically what he
we talks about retail has has something
going for it that's that's very helpful
in terms of getting a message across
think about it in that sense and that's
that it has something called a resting
strangeness I love this phrase that you
use already it stops you in your tracks
because of its strangeness
but it but it forces you to stop and
reassess what you're looking at but
what's interesting is that he doesn't
then go and say they're resting
strangeness is what it is for its own
sake meaning we're not creating a
Pandora like like what's his name
Salvador Dali let's say right okay yeah
no but I I'm specifically said Pandora
because the avatar the movie avatar
because people after they admire they
had watched that they were having
withdrawal syndrome or whatever like
they couldn't they couldn't not be in
the in the imagined fake world of penned
orally they couldn't come back into the
real world and that's that's fantasy
gone bad and that's that's a resting
strangeness for its own sake
right but Tolkien says arresting
strangeness says has a point and but the
point is that it stops you and it forces
you to look at the world that you are in
and to notice it and you and to notice
it with fresh eyes and with fresh
glasses on so to speak and what that
does that it not only forces you to
reassess your relationship with the
created world around you but it makes
you listen to what that created world is
telling you and what fairytales do and
where I rather what fantasy does in in
Tolkien's in Tolkien's system is that it
tells the kind Ori that was actually
reflected in history with the
incarnation of Christ but it also
reflects in a kind of weird not in terms
of history but not in the kind of in the
way that we are trained to look at
history but basically the incarnation of
Christ is the minute came true it's the
it's the bringing down into history of
all of the myths that have been told
before the coming of Christ and all of
the stories that were told the happy
ending stories that were told after his
resurrection and ascension so it's a
kind of view of history that is starting
from a middle point and going outwards
like ripples in a pond as opposed to
starting at a single point sometime in
our past and moving forward towards some
sort of progressive future which is the
way we tend to look at history nowadays
and it's not a very helpful way and it's
certainly not it's certainly not the way
that man used to look at history in the
Middle Ages there's a great article by
yevgeniy for the last king who wrote the
novel Loras which is everybody yes
people asking for a reading list Loris
read loris it's a it's an amazing book
yeah and he's talking about how the
medieval man looked at history none not
as a slide not as a circle because then
there would be nothing more than
repeating patterns we can never get out
of it and that's pretty depressing day
of history but as a helix well I could
look swear it's something there's a
repeating pattern happening throughout
history or events repeat themselves but
they repeat themselves in a different
time and slightly different meaning but
the previous event that it kind of
echoes is no less important and is no
less real even if it never happened and
that's what's so interesting about about
this view of history is that actually
medial a man didn't write fiction
writing fiction was a sin but at the
same time medieval man accepted the fact
that these lives of the saints might
have some things that kind of don't jibe
with with with reality because they
their experience of the divine was
something that happened on a very
everyday level like they say everything
to happen to them whether it's weather
with it whether it's you know the things
that happen to you in your life is a
manifestation of the presence of God and
so for them looking looking at these
reading these stories is a reflection of
reality even though these things might
not be true they are true because they
were they express something very true
about the human human condition and even
if they're they're not positivistic aliy
true meaning they never happened in in
terms of our modern view of history
doesn't make them any less that's true
and actually of all people Neil Gaiman
talks about this a lot in the his
lectures which is fascinating to me
because I don't think he's particular
religious guy but it's it's just the but
there's something about about fairy
tales and and tokine captures it in a
very in a very profound way because he
basically says that man as a created
species has a responsibility to tell
stories because by doing that he is
creating a secondary world in his
stories and in that secondary world he
can he can populate that secondary world
with reflections of the primary world
truth so to speak that makes people
reassess those truths in a new light
because of the arresting strangeness and
so the eternal truths about the human
condition can
be understood in in ways that perhaps
somebody wouldn't be able to accept
listening to a sermon or listening to
somebody just speaking to them across
the across the table Cheers
it's good it's good that you mentioned
game and I think it's important to to
understand when I look at Neil Gaiman's
work I feel like he had a very very
profound intuition at some point about
the the structure of the world and about
the structures not just him but other
people who come from the comic world
like Alan Moore as well but just like
let's say let's say radical feminism
today they also have had a strange
symbolic vision let's say or an
understanding of the symbolic world
it's just that exploring they're
exploring the fringes of it and they
tend to glorify the fringe aspect and so
that's why Gaiman talks about that's why
his characters are you know like the
dream master and Anansi the spider the
trickster all these figures that exists
in the buffer zones of reality and I
think it had I think it's important
because in a way that's where we are oh
yeah today in the world
oh yeah absolute but finding a balance
where that let's say chaotic dream like
world and the more inverted trickster
world is as a place but then connecting
it also to the more heroic figure or
let's say the the memory of our
traditions is has to happen or else or
else you know we're going to we're gonna
get stuck in a Nazis web and then that's
the end of the West for us you know a
Nazis all great with his stories but if
you get stuck in his web your your yeah
your dad yeah well know that and that's
what's so interesting about about
fantasy right now I do maintain that
it's a very powerful genre but it's not
not all the fantasy is able to do that
particularly well we're particularly
well and certainly almost no modern
fantasy is trying to take the journey
back from from the fringes to the center
it's it all of it is sort of glorying in
uncovering the ugliness of the fringes
in particular there's there's this
fantastic series by a writer her name is
NK jemisin it's called the broken earth
series its basically a symbolic
retelling of
of this of slavery in the US but it kind
of moved into a into a far distant
future where the slavery aspect is
flipped around and the dominant race is
dark-skinned and this the slave race is
white skinned but basically it's it's
it's her working through her experience
of being a black woman in the United
States and all the racism and she has to
deal with and it's not able to go very
far at the end of the series in terms of
coming up with with any sort of world
altering solution to this problem it's
it's it stays at the fringes it finds
some sort of transcendence but it's not
able to go very far so we're talking
about my books this is ultimately what
what I'm trying to do with my novels and
that this is why I don't know like get
those with the title do not give us and
give us a little glimpse of what you're
doing so you know what right for okay
well my first novel is called the song
of the Syrian the Syrian being not the
siren of Greek legends but kind of an
inversion of that she is a an amalgam a
half half woman half half bird creature
but rather than being someone whose song
drives you insane
she's someone in from Russian mythology
or kind of folk mythology who calls she
can her song can drive somebody insane
but it's the kind of insanity that
drives them away from the world and
towards paradise so if she's a bird of
paradise that occasionally comes down to
the world and sings to just certain
chosen individuals who then can't rest
until they either hear them hear the
music again or until they leave the
world entirely with with their bodies
and their spirits kind of ascend upwards
so the her song kind of erupts into the
into the world of into my secondary
world which is a kind of fantasy version
of old roots
9th 10th 11th century and the main
character here's here's the song he's
unable to to rest until he does
something with it but basically he's the
hero figure but this is not a
traditional hero story it's it's very
much a kind of a breakdown of the hero
story in the sense that he does have to
go on a journey from from the fringes to
the center but his journey is extremely
convoluted he he's a reflection
me weights it's constantly making
mistakes and constantly trying to get
back back to the center but constantly
you know being drawn back to the fringes
for various reasons
there's the series at large it's a five
five volume series the title of the
whole series is called ravenson which
which is a it's kind of a pun it has to
do with something that happens in book
one so I'm not going to tell you why
it's called ravenson but it does have to
do with the Raven the Raven being kind
of demonic figure in in Russian fairy
tales who plays a very important role in
shaking up the world of my main
character and forcing him to reassess
his reality and try to find the truth
and you which is what we've been talking
about so well so maybe yeah so I maybe
you can tell us a little bit about
Russian fairy tales because one of the
things that has you know my wife is from
Slovakia and one of the great things
about about meeting her I mean obviously
that's so you can't limit it to that but
one of the great things about me
discovering Slavic fairy tales and so
moving you know we might as I talked to
her mother and she showed me these these
old books of a kind of Slovak and Czech
fairy tales and discovering characters
like Baba Yaga and all these amazing
characters finally discovering Russian
fairy tales in the Firebird and you know
all the amazing stories there so maybe
you can tell us a little bit about your
connection to write and maybe maybe how
Russian fairy tales differ a little bit
from the Western fairy tales and and how
you're trying to to plunge into that
yeah absolutely I mean I grew up in this
my first memories are of my parents
telling me telling me these stories
before I went to bed I mean they're my
most vivid memories I still remember the
books that I used to leave the reading
before I could read that the pictures in
them and a lot of those those drawings
and paintings are are so vividly still
stuck in my head they come out in actual
form in my writing I mean I actually I
paint with words those pictures that I
remember from my childhood but they're
they're really interesting I find them
very useful not only because I'm stew in
them so it comes out whether I like it
or not but because they're different
enough
whether it's first of all they're
similar enough to Northern European
fairy tales like like scandal
or German fairy tales that the people
can read them and say oh I kind of
remember this this sort of idea
particularly there's this story about
the the Dragons heart I think it's an
old an old German story about how
there's this evil dragon and he can only
be killed if you find his heart but his
heart is is is stuck inside a chest and
the chest is on top of a tree and like
there's these levels of like or is Orson
in an evil Middle's an egg and the chest
and the chest and top of a tree right so
that that that motif happens in Russian
fairy tales as well very often it has to
do with this character called the
deathless one who's constantly dying
coming back to life like in every fairy
tale the deathless one dies but in the
next fairy tale he's back again so it's
it's just very interesting but in
particular what I find so fascinating
about these is that they are not
traditional good versus evil tales at
all at all they're very messy the main
characters do really stupid things and a
lot of times they're complete morons and
particularly the famous one that
interested informs my first book is the
is one of the many versions of Prince
Yvonne and II and the gray wolf Prince
Ivana's is a sniveling idiot who's
constantly whining and the and what the
only thing that ever happens to him
comes through the agency of this wolf
and we have no idea why this was helping
him he just does and so there's this
there's this wildness about the stories
this this kid this sort of wild chaos
that can be good or it can be bad and it
depends very much it depends very much
on sort of the spiritual state of the
main character and this is particularly
visible in the in the Ivan the idiot
stories because well they're fascinating
in a historical sense as well but the
I'm the idiot stories it's basically the
the youngest son in a family of boys and
he's the one he's lazy he he's literally
described as rubbing the snot off his
nose with the sleeve I mean these images
are just and he sleeps on day on the
pitch from the Russian stove which has a
ledge which is warm the lazy people all
they ever do is sleep on the ledge lazy
people in cats that that's the place for
lazy people in Kansas so he all he ever
does is sleep there and yet when push
comes to shove he gets the princess he
beats the evil Tsar which is a different
conversation has to do with with Russian
Russian history and all that but and
it's not because he's an idiot it's peek
because he's not tied to the to the
rule-bound world of logic yeah of
consequence
he's connected to something different
like he leads with his heart and so
things happen - because he's connected
on some level to the spiritual world and
the spiritual world works through him
because he's not an empty vessel so much
as he's able to let it to kind of
channel through him and baba yaga is a
wonderful example of this because she
can be she can eat you or she can or she
can give you the magical help to go and
defeat the big bad guy and you know it
all depends on on who you are first of
all if you're a woman or a man
traditionally she eats them eats the
boys and it helps the girls which is
interesting and it's alright but also
you have to you have to go through
different kinds of ordeals before she
can help you and this is all very
connected to Russia paganism actually
and if we read go back to even iliyan
well so fascinating about these Russian
fairy tales the way he looks at him is
that they are a bridge between the
cultural world of Russian paganism in
the cultural world of Russian
Christianity and they have a bit of both
and if we the Tolkien writes about this
too in his in his famous essay on the
monsters and the critics where he talks
about Beowulf and how Beowulf although
written by a Christian possibly a
Christian monk celebrates the beauty of
the old yeah wistfully with a kind of
sense of impending loss without willing
to throw out throw out the all of the
old as being inherently bad because it's
connected to paganism he celebrates the
sort of the raw savage beauty of it but
also celebrates the inevitable
transformation of that raw raw savagery
into something that can be tamed and yet
retain that that ember of wildness and
art and that's that's Russian fairy
tales do that very well that they live
in this world that if you study folk
history in particulars of paganism they
live in a pagan world but the characters
oftentimes do Christian things so it's I
think that that's really if when
Christianity goes right that what
happens it seems like one of the things
that Christ does we talked about this in
the Orthodox Church a lot is the
possibility of taking the world and
baptizing it and then you know taking
out of it those things that can continue
on
and that that aren't so wild that they
that they're useless but that they can
you know participate in in the world and
so you know it seems like the best of
Christianity in the Celtic world and in
the northern European world but also in
Rome too you know we really used to the
we're used to the Roman Christianity
because it becomes I'll say the
mainframe for Christianity but a lot of
the Roman world was taken into the
church and and let's say transformed so
that it could be it could be the vehicle
for a civilization basically that yeah
continued on for until today really and
so really when Christianity goes right
that's what that's what it can do its
take these stories and and bring them
into even the Scandinavian stories
people always I always have these
neo-pagans come to me and and talk about
you know oh you know Odin and this and
and all the old pagan stories and I just
laughing in my mind and thinking do you
know who wrote your stories Christians
wrote your stories Asians Christians
wrote your stories they're the ones who
transmitted them they're the ones who
made them participate in in Western
Europe and became part of the thread of
the great the great story of Western
Europe and so you have to at least
acknowledge that before you tell me
about Odin hanging on his tree you know
well I mean that's all don't they hang
on the tree thing is it you know you can
only really appreciate the beauty of
that story if you're looking at history
in the way that it that there's people
who wrote those stories intended whether
the central point of history is not the
deep past it's it's the eruption of the
divine into the into the human and
everything rippled out from that like I
was saying so Odin hanging from a tree
is an echo even though it's in the past
technically right it's still an echo of
the the the story of Christ because
because it's you know time doesn't
matter not in that sense and you also
have to you also kind of have to see
that the reason why the let's say the
Christian the Christian wrote it down
when they when the Scandinavians
converted to Christianity was also
probably because they're they're
probably innumerable versions of the
story of Odin what a few of them got
written down and those that got written
down were the ones that were let's say
capable of emerging into this new world
that was taking form you know yeah
that's something that is that really
needs to be understood because when you
encounter oral
let's say you encounter oral traditions
and oral cultures you'll see that their
their culture their stories are so are
multiple and there's so many versions of
them when they get written down the
question is why was that version written
down and then the whole world view comes
into comes into so the stories I'm I
love the Scandinavian stories as much as
I love that the Russian stories because
I can see in them you know like you said
a preservation of this kind of chaotic
wildness but then also a connection to a
more a more ordered and let's say tame
world at the same time so hopefully that
we can would get all dem well yeah and
at the end and the important thing and
this is where Tolkien comes comes back
again is that every one of the stories
even if they even if they have chaotic
middles they always end happily and that
there is a lot there's a lot to be said
about the happy ending
on a sort of almost ontological level I
hope I'm using that word right but it's
because and Tolkien even says that the
best that the only good oh if you want
your story to be good you have to give
it a happy ending because and it has to
be a very specific kind of happy ending
he talks about something called the you
catastrophe and it's a fascinating thing
because the you catastrophe for him is
basically everything is everything to
the main character everything that can
possibly happen evil and if everything
bad that can possibly happen to my main
character happens and it comes to a
point where there is absolutely no hope
and there's nothing he can do about it
and at the last second there's a turn
and something ineffable or something
without it being Deus Ex man it's mekin
it's not that it's just something where
there's circumstances whether it's he
himself or whether it's people around
him something's shift and suddenly that
all falls away and he's able to come out
triumphant and not only is that a
reflection of course of the of the cross
and then the resurrection but it's also
on a very deep level a reflection of the
human experience because how how often
do we human beings have to go through
absolute hell before we before that
little turn happens and that that
terrible thing that happened to us then
starts to make sense and and gives us
the kind of meaning that then will let
us not only live on but to make
something about our lives that is
beautiful for ourselves and for those
who are who
live around us and for those who see us
and on those different levels the happy
ending is it works and it's very
important so yes tragedy in the Greek
sense has its place in literature but
but the best kinds of stories will
always have happy ending Tolkien says
and I totally agree no and I think I
agree and I think that that it's
something that I had never really
thought about specifically but it makes
sense in terms if you look at Dante and
you look at as if you see if you see
Dante story as bringing together of all
the threads of medieval Christianity
into kind of one massive story you know
you really see that you really see
exactly that that story that you're
talking about that he really frames it
well that basic descent and then then
ascent which nano is everywhere you us
movie anyway
it always is the basic structure of a
story and people are so used to it that
they've actually stopped seeing it they
just almost expect it and and and they
don't understand that that basic frame
which is really a Christian frame has
become their worldview and - and if you
remove Christianity let's say from the
picture you might tumble back into into
the very gloomy underworld of a Greek of
rethinking or a pagan thinking in
general well yeah and it's true and it's
sort of disingenuous I think of a lot of
people too to exist in this story
framework and and to consciously reject
the narrative of Christianity because
because of exactly what you said but at
the same time I think that that that the
stories should still be told in that way
because the reality of that and it's
reflection in the patterns of our own
lives is something that's so profound
that if perhaps repeated enough times
and done done in a good enough way I'm
talking about making writing really
really good literature here and talking
about the kind of the kind of fantasy
that isn't just repeating the the
structure that Tolkien gave to the genre
innocent there's something about people
talk about fantasy being tolkien-esque
so to speak in that that there's this
certain kind of fantasy that's now no
longer in vogue but it's
tolkien-esque actually it's more Terry
Brooks asked because Terry Brooks what
he did whence this is incredible but he
took the Lord of the Rings story and he
rewrote it almost scene for scene but
with different characters and
unfortunately without the the deep
profound underlying structure of
Tolkien's secondary world because
Tolkien had been writing that world
throughout his life and he had been
creating that mythology for himself and
for his country I mean it was it was
literally a mythology for England yeah I
keep doing it his whole life so when
Terry Brooks took this and made it more
bite-sized everybody took after him so
all the elves and the dwarves and the
orcs and all that stuff we see recycled
over and over again and even the even
the the wizard figure the halfling
figure the you know the the young the
young man the aunjanue quest to come out
and find himself in the world and I mean
the ending of The Sword of Shannara is
remarkably banal and we compared to
compared to what happens in in the Lord
of the Rings it's basically a message of
self-realization like you know I am what
I am Who I am and that's great
sorry you've missed the point you've
gone through it you've gone through a
thousand pages of this you know terrible
ordeals and all you can come up with is
that I am Who I am
that's lovely okay I mean one of the
things about token that I really
appreciate and I think one of the
reasons why he can also give us a
solution to the morass we're in is that
he creates a hierarchy let's say of you
know of beings you know he creates this
this traditional really is like a
traditional hierarchy of beings that
kind of ascend and up to there the the
creator figure what but he also does is
he he spends the whole book The Lord of
the Rings talking about the value of the
lowest rung of that hierarchy and how
that lets say the periphery can act as a
frame and a guardian let's say or a
holder of the or of the of the tradition
and is the one that's able to kind of
carry it through to to the end of the
story and so the Hobbit is the only one
who can carry this ring this periphery
and and bring it to its you know being
able to to let's say throw it into the
fire so that it doesn't consume the
world and then kind of restart the world
so it's a it's not and so that's why
that's why it's the
hero figure in the Lord of the Rings
isn't you know Eragon isn't the king
although he's important in the story
yeah it's the smallest figure who then
is able to to to restart the the whole
the whole story and so to me that kind
of helps us it's a it's something it's a
lesson for our age they say to try to
understand the places in the margin and
the periphery that can help us to to
flip things back on their on their feet
let's say well yeah well what's what's
so interesting about that is that it was
largely an accident that Tolkien
included the hobbits and his larger in
this larger world because he wrote The
Hobbit as a separate thing and it
gradually became part of the larger
mythos but it was possibly the most
brilliant thing that he ever did because
there's they're so grounded in everyday
reality they're so set apart from the
from the epic that in that inhabits the
world Vista marillion for example and
yet they're within it and they're in
there part of that world and even though
they are a 19th century English
gentleman from from the country there
there's still you know encountering the
kings of old and for our time this is
why it's it's why I think I think this
is why it's such a popular book is
because whether he intended to or not he
was able to exactly do that to talk
about the the exalted things the epic
things that they're really true things
about the heart but through the prism of
the small men of the smallest person you
know and if there's one line in the
movie that I can sort of I mean it's
kind of cliched but it but it's true it
reflects Tolkien's worldview even if
even if it's spoken in the language of
self self-help books but it's when
Galadriel tells Frodo even the smallest
person can make a difference and of
course if you take it out of this
context it sounds like yeah go you know
go to the seer yourself help I'll pull
out a book and you can become a
best-seller in five seconds but it's not
that it's that it's even the downtrodden
even those who have no hope even those
who or the literally smallest who have
no strength they can topple kingdoms but
it's not because of them it's because
they are able to put their trust into
the larger story and Sam talks about
this incredibly on the way to Mordor
when they're about to lose faith he
reminds Frodo that they are actors in a
larger story and that they
are going to be sung about the people
gonna sing about them later as as
members of that larger story and they're
no longer going to be halflings but
they're going to be legends but in the
dirty reality of real life they have to
just one foot in front of the other one
foot in front of the other do what you
have to because this is this is what you
have been given this is your duty and
Tolkien was very big on duty and if
that's all you need to do and in the end
even though Frodo
cannot do what he's supposed to do he
fails right he's not the hero he fails
right and some people consider that him
you know Gollum taking the ring and
falling office as being the biggest
cop-out in the history of literature but
actually it's a very realistic and very
accurate depiction on purpose by talking
of the way the Providence works in this
fallen world of shadows because also if
you see Gollum as if you see Gollum as a
kind of mere reflection of Frodo I think
that's not it's not a strange way to see
it you can almost see Gollum as the dark
side of Frodo like okay they're just one
being there Hinton in the story that
that show that you know Gollum is what
Frodo could become if you let himself go
and so the fact that that at the end
it's that it's kind of like death
you know the idea of conquering death by
death and how this dark fallen figure
finally you know even despite himself is
the one who goes goes into the fire with
the ring and it's as if you know as if
also his dark side is going into the
fire with that ring as well so I and I
don't think it's a cop-out at all I
think it's a great great great idea yeah
I do too yeah for sure
look we've been going for about an hour
and so she's got some great stuff we
should we should probably do this again
another conversation but maybe just just
to finish us off just tell people again
the the title of your new series of your
books where they can get them and also
where they can connect with you online I
know you've got a website and you've got
a blog you're doing all this stuff so
maybe give give us give us your
shoutouts and and we'll set up another
conversation at some point okay sounds
great okay so the series is the Raven
Sun series you can find it anywhere
Brooks what Brooks or sold on Amazon
particular I do have paperback versions
for those of you who think that
independently published authors only do
ebooks no I have
paper book paperback versions as well my
website is Nicolas coat are calm and if
you will if you don't mind Jonathan I
will do a shout out for the Kickstarter
right now I don't know when this videos
going to come out but until February 7th
I have a Kickstarter going to fund the
rest of the series books 4 and 5 that's
been going very very well and the reason
I want to bring it up is because it's an
opportunity for people who like to
listen to audiobooks to get access to my
first three audiobooks which have not
yet been produced basically for as low
as five five dollars
I mean I'm opening up I'm hoping it up
as a free gift to anybody who
contributes at the five-dollar level or
higher so it's an opportunity to help me
yeah on a purely monetary level but it's
also an opportunity for people if they
want to experience my writing and also
they can win a carving by knee that I'm
going to make I'm good how could I
forget that I'm gonna carve carve
Assyrian for initially so to participate
in his Kickstarter so you can win a
carving by me if you help Nicholas
publishes books I can't believe I forgot
that yeah so basically whoever gives I
think fifty dollars or over maybe it was
twenty dollars or over will have a
chance will be put into a draw for this
carving song yeah there we go so
Nicholas is great is great talking to
you and I for sure will we'll try to do
this again all right Jonathan great
thank you so I hope you enjoyed my
discussion with Nicholas make sure you
check out his webpage and his
Kickstarter to even get a chance to win
a carving by me who knows um I have a
few announcement to make I'm going to do
a movie interpretation in collaboration
with another channel called the
storytellers they've already used some
of my the way that I discuss symbolism
to to interpret other movies and so I'll
put a link to their page down below and
we're going to do Pacific Rim which is
might be surprising to some but there's
a lot of great stuff in that movie to
talk about another little thing is I'm
going to start putting affiliate links
in the description for the books that I
talked about during a video so if I
talked about a book
I'll put an affiliate link in
the description if you want to buy the
book it's a little way to buy it and
also encourage me at the same time and
so another video coming soon and yeah
talk to you again